here now a man who was with Flynn
from the campaign to transition and who
sat face to face with Muller Rudy
Guiliani former New York City Mayor Rudy
today seemed to signify the real
beginning of the unraveling of the deep
state as we know it
do you agree I I believe this is a very
important day first of all justice has
been done for a man who's been treated a
totally unjustifiable way and this is a
man that the Obama administration was
out to get from the time that he
wouldn't lie for them and it has
something to do with him and it has
something to do with the fact that they
knew they were trying to frame Trump and
they didn't want Flynn in the way they
wanted Flynn out because they thought he
was the only one that really would
understand that tricks there's a lot to
what Comey was saying when he said he
wouldn't have tried this on a more
experienced administration and they
wanted Flynn out of the way because they
knew they were going to carry out struck
insurance policy to remove illegally a
sitting president of the United States
these people are terrible people it's
one of the worst things that's happened
on history and they should be prosecuted
for conspiracy today
Rudy Rudy Newhouse Intel documents that
were revealed they revealed something
very interesting Obama knew all the
details of the wiretap the phone calls
with kis lyac so this wasn't all that
surprising this and by the way remember
when they they said that he had to be
kept in the loop remember that little
memo you know struck and all of that
you're not surprised I I'm not surprised
I know I'm not by the American bomber
probably Obama
I mean Flynn outed Obama years before I
mean three four years before when Obama
wanted him to lie about Isis I mean
Flynn put Flint and Flint knew where the
bodies were buried so fund was a
dangerous man
and it isn't just to get Trump it's to
facilitate their attempt to get Trump
they wanted Flynn out of the way and
they had attempted it before they
started an investigation of 2017 on a
ridiculous foreign agent Registration
Act case so this this this and they held
on to the case they held on to the case
they never really prosecuted it because
they'd achieved their objective by
leaking it but then when Muller came in
and then he had Weitzman around that
would prosecute you know a little baby
or anything if they had anything to a
Trump they brought the case that was
probably the stupidest thing they did
they really had achieved their objective
when they got him fired but they were so
dark here's how to go ahead and try to
prosper hold on here's how here's how
Adam Schiff responded Rudy to the DOJ is
dropping a twin case we lost 50 years
worth of ground in solidifying the
Independence of the Justice Department
after Watergate was back in the category
of most an emerging democracy where the
rule of law is not yet firmly
established where prosecutorial
decisions are made on the basis of
politics it all gets back to sort of the
Rudy Giuliani truth is in truth
Kellyanne Conway we're entitled to our
own alternate facts world that Donald
Trump lives in Rudy since when is Adam
Shipman concerned about the truth
I think Adam Schiff is part of the
conspiracy to unseat a lawfully elected
president lying for two years
misrepresenting that he had material
evidence which he didn't have we take a
good look we take a good look at that
whistleblower
it's gonna take you right back to the
beginning you know that Adam Schiff has
been involved in this from the beginning
and some of them are easy
I mean Comey and struck and page and
possibly clapper and Brennan but did it
go as high as Obama and can you get
shift those are the two big questions
but I think Schiff has been a part of
this almost from the beginning Rudy
thank you so much great to see you
tonight
I just completes he's a complete
sleazebag